Let's see, where are we going next? We are
taking taking calls. Let's go to Sara Thack
from I believe it's Boise, Idaho. Is that correct?
Yeah, that is Boise, Idaho. How are you doing?
I'm kind of in, like, the Meridian Eagle
area, but pretty close to Boise. Love it.
So what's on your mind?
Yes, so I just wanted to say,
like I'm a big fan of your show. It
really got me through this election
and all the ups and downs all the time
thinking. I guess my question is like
with with what Trump's doing, do you think
there will be like a Republican civil war or
do you think Trump already kind of won it and
that it's now the party of Trump? Because I saw
Kyle Kolinsky talking about that quite a bit.
And I just wanted to see what your take was.
I think we don't know yet. And so right now,
you're seeing factions that are very angry with
each other. Earlier this week, Mitch McConnell
acknowledged that Joe Biden is president elect
and Trump attacked him on Twitter. And then the
Kuhnen people started tweeting. They're leaving
the Republican Party. And you have Trump
attacking Republican Georgia Governor Brian
Camp and Republican Georgia Secretary of State
Obrad Raffensperger, because they're apparently
unwilling to overtly try to help Trump steal the
election. They were fine trying to do it by voter
suppression. It didn't work. And now that's kind
of where they're drawing the line. I just don't
think we know yet. I think the Georgia results
will give us a signal, given how close it's been.
If the Democrats end up winning Georgia by a
significant margin, I think it will be a sign
that the Republican civil war hasn't is real and
has an impact. But really, what I think the factor
the the what we need to wait for is how visible is
Trump after January 20th? Because I'll tell you,
if Trump disappears and just goes to play
golf and stops tweeting or even gets banned
by Twitter once he's not protected as a world
leader, I think it will completely deflate the
sails of the kuhnen of the cultists and of those
folks. And we see the Republican Party reunite,
pretend to care about the debt and just
oppose Democrats. If Trump remains visible or
he is replaced invisibility by some of his
kids or whatever, if they keep it going,
that will continue the divisions between the
Trump cult and the sort of more mainstream
Republican Party. I just don't think we're
going to know that until after January 20th.
OK, and so, like, if they do, like, either
Trump runs again or like he announces it
during Biden's inauguration. Yeah. Or is like he
buys Newsmax and then he starts his own Trump TV.
Do you think that's that's the way that we have
a civil war, just going to go back to the normal
status quo kind of essential party?
That's my view as of right now. Yeah.
Thank you so much.
My pleasure. Great to hear from
Boise, Idaho, close to close to Boise, Idaho.